what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel and welcome to
Pearl daily where I talk about this
week's treachery debauchery and
craziness so today shout out to the
production team King and blessing we are
in our brand new studio yay
[Music]
um before I start though guys make sure
you like the video and subscribe to the
channel and ring that notification Bell
alright so our first story today
we have you know us modern women just
have really tough problems you know I
know the men out there are out building
the buildings
um you know doing all the sewers garbage
collection but us women like we're
really oppressed in this Society we have
such a tough time so there was an only
fans model that came forward with um you
know just some really huge life
struggles that she's going through so
pull the pull the clip King
so I went to Google I went to Google I
put pinky doll naked and I clicked on
pictures and what I see what I see
there's a lot of page there's a lot of
page you keep swiping and swiping
swiping it don't stop it don't stop and
I see all this website how dare you
you're gonna let other people put my
face my body out here doing stuff like
that how dare you without asking an ID
where's the ID turns tell me that what's
up I'ma tell you I'ma tell you something
today I'ma Sue all of you all of you are
gonna sue you I'm gonna sue you y'all
want to play with me you're allow the
people post big job really cause you
know you're about to get paid well guess
what I'm about to get all that money all
that money okay so for those of you that
didn't know what she was talking about
this only fans model was very upset
because she typed her name on Google
and she was shocked that her only fans
content was not behind a paywall so for
those of you that don't know I did cover
this chick a couple of months uh maybe
weeks ago where she was going viral for
making basically sounds on Tick Tock you
know what swimming we're really breaking
the glass ceiling
we're really breaking barriers out here
and just you know becoming Millionaires
and billionaires through hard work and
adversity and yeah so this chick was
making
um sounds on Tick Tock and was going
viral and then she was she decided you
know let me just capitalize even more
only fans and now she is devastated that
her nudes have been leaked
and now she is going to sue all of you
so all of you that leaked her nudes
um watch out because the lawsuit is
coming it is coming
um but guys this is the problem in
society remember one out of every 25 of
us under the age of 35
is literally on only fans and that
doesn't include the chicks the Instagram
models that you know accept trips and
other uh Petty forms of prostitution
that women do on the daily and you know
I I was thinking about this and I really
think that and only fans in the dating
Market is the equivalent of jail time on
job history
yeah so you know
um women are gonna do crazy crazy [__]
but my issue is when
the whining
another woman whining about the choices
that she picked I mean did anyone put a
gun to your head
and make you put your nudes on the
internet did anyone put a gun to your
head and say ma'am
only fans is the way no no and you know
even with all of this we still get
whining later
and now the patriarchy is just out
together because her nudes have been
leaked even though she posted them